all right kaun kaun what an amazing day
this has been I've been hanging out for
pretty much the entire day I didn't
catch all of the speakers but I caught
most of them and I've learned a lot and
I'm sure you're all learning a lot too
and so this has been just a fantastic
day thank you so much to the hustle for
putting this together thanks to the
Brava theater I love this space
this has been just a great day so since
I am the last speaker today I wanted to
take a step back or perhaps a step up
change perspective a little bit think a
bit about some of the fundamentals of
what we do as content creators I am a
content creator I come from a writing
background and so the quality of content
is extremely important to me personally
and I want to make sure that we're
talking about some of these fundamental
issues that maybe you already know but
it's easy to forget about when we get
caught up in the rush of trying to meet
those deadlines and meet those targets
and as important as it is as vital as it
is that we are data-driven and that we
you know really do have those processes
in place and that we you know really use
numbers as much as we can we optimize
and we measure in the end we are human
beings talking to human beings and if we
don't connect on that core level and
everything we do is meaningless and
there's a big problem that content
creators face and it's huge and it's
scary and it's simply this
there's too much content too much
content is ubiquitous and ephemeral and
those are words you should probably not
use in your content but I'm going to use
them here ubiquitous it is everywhere
ephemeral it is temporary there's so
much coming at us all the time from so
many channels in this constant stream
most of it doesn't get to our retinas it
doesn't get to our brains we can't
process it there are almost 8,000 tweets
going live every second
of everyday I don't remember who it was
earlier today who was bad-mouthing
Twitter but um yeah that many tweets and
life span of between something like 15
minutes if you blink you miss it if you
miss it it's gone forget it is it any
wonder then that in a survey of some
marketing leaders that was conducted
recently I think was by bright edge more
than two-thirds admitted probably very
reluctantly that more than half of their
content isn't being consumed ok we're
creating content I'm using the general
we all of us who create content we're
creating content that people aren't
reading that people aren't watching that
people aren't taking any action on what
the hell are we doing right where are we
going wrong we're probably going wrong
in a bunch of different places you might
be creating the wrong content we might
be serving it up to the wrong audience
we might be putting into the wrong place
we might be serving up at the wrong time
or maybe we're just creating content
that people don't actually want and
that's what I'm gonna talk about for the
rest of this time today now we create
content and when we're doing it because
we're so close to it it looks big and
glorious to us and we're so proud of it
and maybe it is big and maybe it is
glorious and maybe it's really
high-quality and it's really great but
that should be animating it's not
animating when you put it out in the
world it's just this one little drop in
this steady stream of stuff that's
constantly passing by passing by passing
by so how do we make sure that the
content we create even if it is really
good how do we make sure that people are
actually gonna stop and see it and
notice it and take some sort of action
with it and here's another way to look
at this problem and I think it's really
important to remember this because this
is something else that's really easy to
forget just because you're creating a
piece of content doesn't mean anybody's
seeing it just because somebody's seeing
it doesn't mean they're noticing it okay
I can see all of you in this room how
many of your individual faces are
actually imprinting on my consciousness
very few and don't take that personally
it's it's not you it's me
it's the way my brain works its way all
our brains work we can only notice so
much and when there's a steady stream of
content coming at us we can't notice a
whole lot just because you notice
something doesn't mean you want to
engage with it I saw a lot of stuff I
noticed a lot of stuff on the sidewalk
this morning I did not want to engage
with any of it
just because you do engage with a piece
of content doesn't mean you're
necessarily getting the message that the
creator of the content was trying to
impart it to you and none of that
matters if the content doesn't actually
drive the person to change their
attitudes change their way of thinking
or take some sort of an action so it's
not enough just to be present it's not
enough just to be seen and you'll notice
I put a little green line in that slide
what's above that line you know if
you're smart you have a good strategy
and you do you know you cross all the
SEO check off all the ex-ceo boxes and
you put in a little money you can make
sure that your content is getting in
front of eyeballs everything below that
line the content has to carry on its own
right just because something lands in my
inbox doesn't mean I'm going to take any
action on it I've must get hundreds of
emails a day there are only a few that I
actually I'm gonna be motivated open and
those are you know the ones that I think
are gonna have some real value to me so
how do we get across the green line how
do we go from being seen to being
noticed I can think of a couple of good
ways to do that one is to be really
obnoxious and make everyone hate you you
can take a picture of some toe fungus
and you can put some sort of a clickbait
headlines on it and you can saturate
every ad network there is you know what
I'm talking about you've seen these you
can do that that sort of content will
get noticed it will get clicked but
those clicks have very low value right
it's not necessarily that people want to
interact with your content it's just
like it's there it's it's everywhere
they can't avoid clicking it's this is
not what you're actually going after
there's another way to get noticed and I
think it's a much better approach you
can make content that matters you can
make content that people actually want
they want to see that they want to
interact with that they want to read
that they want to save that they want to
share with their friends that they want
to take some sort of an action on and
people want this there was a huge study
done by I think it's the Havas group
I think they talked to something like
three hundred thousand people around the
world and they surveyed 1,500 brands and
what they found was 84 percent of the
people they talked to want brands to
provide some sort of meaningful content
content that tells a story or that
entertains or that informs or that
creates an experience content solves a
problem that's worth saying again
meaningful content entertains and
informs it's worth your time it makes
your day a little bit better makes your
life a little bit better it tells a
story it gives me some sort of a
situation that I can project myself into
and make myself the hero of that story
and see how it effects me and see how
whatever it is you're trying to tell me
whatever it is you're trying to sell can
make my life better it provides a
solution and that solution is not
necessarily by Brand X if I'm with
Evernote and we're talking about being
more productive being more organized the
solution that I'm going to put in the
piece of content is not necessarily
download Evernote it's going to be more
like okay think about the things that
you really want think about what matters
to you think about what's a priority for
you write it all down write down why
come back to that note in a month see if
that's still what matters to you and why
and by the way I know a great product
where you can do that
that's Evernote meaningful content also
creates experiences now that can be
something like really immersive a video
quiz some sort of a game or it can just
be a really well-written blog post that
draws you in and makes you want to know
more and keeps drawing you in like
little breadcrumbs right like Hansel and
Gretel you just keep going and going and
going
now because we know that people want
this if you are creating that kind of
content you have a huge advantage
because this is the stuff that people
are already actively looking for right
they're gonna see it because they're
looking for it right now now that
doesn't mean you don't have to do any
work right you still have to do all of
the hard work of you know making sure
that you guys you know is right making
sure that you're putting the content
into the right places and making sure
that you're putting it there at the
right time but people are more likely to
see it like I mentioned I've got all
these these emails come into my inbox
every day you know they're only two or
three that I'm gonna bother opening yeah
obviously the hustle because it's great
and you know the audible daily deal
because I know that the chances of that
content being something I care about are
much higher than all that other stuff
that's in my inbox which I'm probably
just going to ignore okay yeah I know
little acronyms little mnemonics are
kind of corny but I happen to like them
and I like you know I like cream a la
who doesn't like cream it's rich and
it's flavorful and I think it's a good
metaphor for content because cream rises
to the top and that's what we want our
content to do right so creamy content
it's content which is consistent it is
recognizably yours it is on brand it is
on message all the time it is relevant
it is content that speaks to your core
audiences needs and aspirations and
dreams and fears it is engaging like I
said those breadcrumbs it's gonna draw
you in deeper and deeper and deeper as
you go it's actionable it doesn't live
in a vacuum it's not this little island
this one piece of content it connects to
this larger world and it takes people on
a journey and it's masterful and this is
the writer and me again quality content
adheres to high standards of editorial
and design but that also refers to how
you go about creating the content let's
dig in a little deeper
c is for can
on brand on message recognizably yours
so there's an example up here which is a
snippet of the Evernote homepage and a
great rule of thumb is if you cover up
your logo and cover up your brand name
is your content still recognizably yours
or could it be anybody's
or even worse could it be your
competitors so of course we have our
logo and our name on the home page but
not in this particular snippet there's
no elephant logo there there's no way
Evernote what we do have is this phrase
remember everything and this is a phrase
which is very closely associated with
Evernote we've used it for years it is
our biggest tagline we've tried other
tag lines over the years but you know
what we keep coming back to this one
because this one encapsulate s' the
Evernote brand in two words and there
are words that resonate with people when
people talk about Evernote this is what
they say it's my second brain it helps
me remember everything and it's very
aspirational and inspirational and
people connect connect with it super
easily and right below that there's
another phrase which I happen to like
very much organize your work and
declutter your life again this is very
succinct it's very concise it's very
aspirational it's easy to connect to and
it's also in just those few words that's
what eight words altogether remember
everything organize your work declutter
your life it's setting a tone and
establishing a voice that we can use
throughout all the content we create
it's saying that we are friendly and we
are helpful and that we care about you
so if you want to create consistent your
content to yourself I do highly
recommend you have some sort of a style
guide you don't have to go nuts with
this but it is key to creating
consistent content that you can use for
all the stuff you do that other people
in your organization who are creating
content can use that new people when
they come into your organization can use
so that you never wander off script that
you're always on message on brand and we
call it a style guide but really it
covers four separate things that people
tend to conflate people tend to mix up
but the really they are different here's
your voice
what's your brand's personality what
the Keith aspects the key features of
the way your brand expresses itself and
that's something that applies
universally across all the content you
create there's your message which is
what is it exactly you're trying to say
what is your value proposition then
there's your tone which people always
confuse with voice tone is situational
if your voice is universal your tone
apply is how do you take that voice and
apply it to an upsell email how do you
apply it to an error message how do you
apply it to a how-to article or a video
your voice should be the same in all of
these things but each has a different
tone you might be very upbeat and
aggressive you might be very sober and
even apologetic in some cases there are
it all depends on what the situation is
that your content consumer finds
themselves in at that time and then
there's the style itself which is the
house rules you know do you use the
Oxford comma
do you use ap style how do you
capitalize things if you don't have a
style guide or if your style guide you
use some work there are a bunch of
really good ones that happen to be
publicly available you can go there you
can steal them you can make use of them
yourself I've mentioned three here
MailChimp is well known as kind of a
gold standard they actually have two
websites one is voice and tone calm
which covers that situational stuff I
mentioned earlier how do you and don't
you talk in specific situations and
that's hugely important it's not just
about here are the rules but here are
some good examples and good counter
examples this is gonna work this isn't
going to work for our brand 18f you'll
notice that's a.gov and I know that's
kind of scary but what they do is really
interesting they partner with government
agencies that have huge and very complex
content repositories and they help them
simplify them and make them
understandable regular human beings
we're at least that's the idea so if you
have very technical content in your
organization you might want to look at
what 18f does because they've really
thought this through very well
and then I also mentioned BuzzFeed you
know ap style is kind of a default for a
lot of organizations some of you are
actually in the content creation
business and
very journalistic great if you're not if
you're more of a startup then maybe ap
style which is created by journalists
for journalists isn't exactly what you
need BuzzFeed might be a little bit more
relevant to you so I recommend you check
those out quality content is relevant
it's about the customer not about you
this is an example that headline says
you're not being lazy routines and
breaks are good for you and it's part of
a series that we're doing about wellness
and how it interacts with productivity
because you know productivity isn't just
about getting more done and drinking 20
Red Bulls and staying up 20 hours a
night it's very much like content
creation itself do you want to do more
work or do you want to do more
meaningful work if you want to do more
meaningful work you should take care of
yourself and that's the message we're
you know we're purveying here and this
is something that again can connect to
people on a very personal level
especially the kind of people who are
likely to have an interest in Evernote
because they're very driven and maybe
they're feeling a little bit guilty
about the fact that they want to take a
break once in a while and we're gonna
tell them yes that's okay and so this
isn't actually about Evernote at all
we'll find ways to put Evernote in there
but it's more about reaching out to a
broader audience with something that's
relevant to them something that is
evergreen we can always use that we can
repurpose that we can put into a bunch
of different kinds of media and
gradually making the association between
this self-improvement making you feel
better they can be better and our brand
if you want to create relevant content
of course you have to get inside the
consumers head you have to do your
homework you have to do your research
you have to ask them what they care
about what is on their minds you have to
do your tracking you have to really find
out what people want and care about from
that you can build some personas now I
see a lot of companies kind of going
nuts with personas and they've got you
know names and photos and you know not
just that and their occupation but you
know we know were they like bocce ball
and we know what they had for breakfast
this morning and we know how they like
their coffee and some organizations can
do that and make great results with it
and if you're one of them awesome but I
see
usually that kind of persona wise up not
being used I would rather see a simple
practical persona that's just about sort
of the type of person and the type of
things they care about and that I can
easily keep in my mind and not get
distracted by all that minutia which
makes me think Oh makes me start to
second-guess myself when I'm creating a
piece of content oh I don't know if Mary
would actually like this because this is
about soccer and she likes bocce ball
missing the point once you've got their
personal personas what do you have to
offer them what is the unique thing that
they can get out of your product that
they won't get out of any other product
and there's this great quote I don't
know who originally said that I've seen
it attributed to a bunch of different
people which means it was probably none
of them but it's sell a good night's
sleep
about the mattress it's not about you
it's not about your features it's about
what your core audience needs quality
content is engaging it speaks to
audience interests in ways that resonate
now one of my favorite parts of my job
is I get to do the company podcast it's
a place where we can get into really
in-depth content with really interesting
people we just did one with Chris
Hardwick who I love I had to put away
all of my fanboy impulses there and
that's